[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: Hi, everybody.
Thank you for being
here with me today.
I'm so pleased to be
here and have a chance
to introduce our guest
speaker today, Mary Risley.
She's the founder
of Food Runners.
She has been one
of the proponents
of this program for decades.
And she's also just
a fascinating person.
And please join me in
welcoming Mary Risley.
MARY RISLEY: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Hi, everybody.
So let's see.
What am I talking about today.
So first of all, number one is
it's really good to see you,
and I think the food here
is the best I've ever
seen in a corporate cafeteria.
It was fantastic.
And thank you for
all the excess food
that you give Food Runners.
We are picking up
masses of food every day
and taking it directly
to the shelters
where it is either
served that night
or chilled and
served the next day.
So it really, really means
a lot to the shelters
in San Francisco.
What's the story
about Mary Risley.
Mary Risley was
a young woman who
drove across the Trans-Canada
Highway in a blue Mustang
50 years ago and
came down to San
Francisco in the Summer of Love
when everybody was sharing.
They were sharing sex,
apartments, marijuana,
and it was a major influence
to me, the Summer of Love.
And by the way, I still
have the blue Mustang.
And that was 50 years ago.
I tried for five years
to be a secretary
and wear pantyhose and go
up in a corporate office
and try to get the men to
think they want to marry me,
and none of it worked.
And so after five
years, I said fuck this.
And somebody said, what have
you always wanted to do.
And I said, I've always wanted
to be a cooking teacher.
So I started teaching cooking
in a ratty Leavenworth Street
apartment.
I handwrote the recipes.
I walked down to a bank at
California in Montgomery.
Somebody copied them on
a Xerox machine for free,
and I went home and
taught everybody
what I'd learned in
Mastering the Art of French
Cooking" by Julia Child.
So I am a big fraud.
That was in 1973.
And 1979, I started a full time
culinary school, Tante Marie's.
And if you Google Mary
Risley, you will see my video.
How many people have
already done that?
[LAUGHTER]
The video I made five years
ago, which is timely now,
is just put the fucking
turkey in an oven,
have a glass of wine, take a
walk, and don't worry about it.
Thank you.
Thank you, YouTube.
Thank you, Google.
So you go to
tantemarie.com, my website,
you will see there
are 350 recipes
on how to cook and 32 YouTube
videos on how to cook.
And of course, now
I'm out of date
because people are putting
videos on other things
and things like that.
But I'm a very
lucky girl that I've
been able to support myself as a
cooking teacher for the last 45
years.
The next thing-- am I OK
in the picture up there?
Do I look OK?
Yes, I look skinny
and beautiful.
[LAUGHTER]
What is Food Runners?
Food Runners was started in 1987
with me and a group of women.
And what we do is we
provide any business
in San Francisco with
the free service--
hi-- free service of picking up
their leftover perishable and
prepared foods and taking
it to the shelters,
taking it to what I
call the shelters.
It's really the neighborhood
feeding programs.
And so what happens is
we have currently 200
volunteers in their own
car, one paid truck driver--
a man running around in a
van, his own van, who's paid--
and two bike couriers.
And what those
people are doing is
picking up leftover
perishable and prepared foods
and taking it right
from the donor
to the people that are going to
serve it that night for dinner.
We do have a slideshow to go
with a PowerPoint presentation.
So if we have it up, we could
talk a little bit about my PP--
it's called a PPP I understand,
a PowerPoint presentation.
No idea how to use
something like that myself.
A little bit earlier, I
talked about my coming
to San Francisco 50 years
in the Summer of Love,
and that was a time when
people were sharing.
It was also a time when it was
cheap to live in San Francisco,
if you can believe that.
And so what we do is
we provide businesses
in San Francisco with this
free service of picking up
their leftover food.
You might have heard of the
San Francisco food bank.
The food bank is a
huge building down
in Indiana Street,
which is a warehouse
of nonperishable foods.
People like Kellogg's
and Del Monte
can donate green beans that
have that wrong label on them
or cereals or stuff like that.
Food Runners takes to over 300
different neighborhood feeding
programs, but those programs
can go to the San Francisco food
bank and buy food
like in a shopping
cart for $0.18 a pound.
It's donated food.
The $0.18 goes to pay
for the operating costs.
But what do you do with
the trays of lentils
with mushrooms, that dairies
of noodles with pork?
That can't go to a big warehouse
down on Indiana Street.
So that's why Food Runners
started 30 years ago,
to supplement what the
food bank can't do.
And currently, this is--
so we could-- currently,
we're delivering food directly
to places around town, as I
said earlier, that can serve
it that night or the next day.
So what is food waste?
Food waste is a--
no, let's go back to
that previous one.
Let's go back to the previous--
who's doing that?
Who's clicking?
You are.
Oh she is.
[LAUGHTER]
So wait a minute.
I saw Jon Stewart last night.
He was hiding behind
something like this.
Wait, I can do it.
Let me do it.
Show me how to do it.
Oh yeah, I can't do it.
OK, here we go.
I want to do one
and then the other?
OK, so look at this.
So these are the statistics.
So the estimate is that 40%
of the food in the country
is discarded, and 20% of the
food that is bought and taken
home is discarded.
And as you know, there are
so very, very many people
that are going to bed hungry.
And one of the big problems
in this city, I think,
is that if people have an
apartment and two or three
kids, I mean, they
can usually pay rent,
but they don't have
enough for food.
So there's a lot
of hungry people.
You've seen it all
down here, right?
You see it all the time.
So when we're talking
about rescuing
perishable and prepared
foods, the first thing
that comes to
everybody's mind is--
when you go into a store
or go into a business,
do you ever throw food away?
They say, oh no, we
never throw food away.
Well here's our card,
here's the phone number,
here's our website.
And then they will say, oh,
it's not the company policy.
Well, who do I talk to
to change the policy?
And then we're worried
about liability.
Well, the bottom line
is in the United States,
nobody has ever sued after
receiving donated food,
and the donor has
been protected by laws
since the '80s in California
and what's commonly
called the Good
Samaritan Act in the '90s
that Bill Clinton signed.
So there is no need to--
OK, I'm going to try it.
Do do do do, it didn't work.
[LAUGHTER]
So there's no need
to fear liability.
And so listen to this.
So where does Food
Runners pick up food?
We've been picking up at Whole
Foods at Franklin in California
ever since they started.
We pick up at every
Trader Joe's in the city,
every Trader Joe's in the city.
Listen, Trader Joe's doesn't
want publicity about it.
They just do it out of the
goodness of their heart,
and they give us milk.
Next one please.
[LAUGHTER]
They give us milk, meat,
dairy, flowers that have all
gone by their expiration date.
Expiration dates doesn't
mean a fucking thing.
What happens is it is
something that was created by--
it's at the
manufacturer's discretion
to put on the expiration date--
buy by, expires after,
blah, blah, blah.
There's nothing.
I myself have kept a
chicken, a cooked chicken,
and eaten it three weeks
after I roasted it.
I've cooked with eggs six
weeks after I bought them.
I've got cream in my fridge
that has an expiration
date of it of October 26.
I open it up, smell
it, and use it.
You know that?
I mean, we all know that.
Don't throw it out until
it starts to smell.
When I was at cooking school
in France 150 years ago,
the chefs used to break
the egg and open it up
and smell it to
see if it was bad.
Can you imagine that?
We don't get bad eggs.
So where does food
waste come from?
Where does food waste come from?
The bottom line is the first
place that it comes from
is the farmer doesn't want to
pay to have somebody go through
and pick the strawberries again.
So if the strawberries
or the peppers
weren't ripe when he
hires the migrant workers,
he doesn't want to pay
to have somebody go back
and get it again.
So nowadays, there's
groups called gleaners
that are trying to go and get
the produce from the farms
after the pickers
have gone through.
The next thing that
happens, as you know,
is that the guy sorting the
apples at the distribution
center--
this one he can sell.
This one he can't.
This one he can sell.
So the ones that he can't sell
were used to be discarded.
It wasn't worth his while.
But now there's a group
here that will go and get
what they call imperfect food.
So that's a good one.
The huge place for sources
food that we just talked about
is grocery stores.
We pick up at Whole Foods,
Trader Joe's, Gus's, we
pick up, all over town, the food
that the grocery guy doesn't
want to put out or the food
that doesn't sell and is
a little too old.
So that's what
Food Runner is for.
And then another big
thing is, as you know,
we just talked about 20% of the
food taken home is discarded.
And I have to say,
the other day,
I threw out five
carrots that had
been in the bottom
of my fridge forever.
They were just pretty bad
looking, wilted carrots.
They actually looked
like something
that Dominique Crenn would cook.
She likes them all--
[LAUGHTER]
She likes to roast carrots
for 54 hours or something.
But anyway, the reason I
put my website up there,
the tantemarie.com
website, is, as I said,
there are 350 recipes on there.
We have a group of young--
I say that in order
to get young and rich,
you have to have blond
hair in San Francisco,
and then you have to drive
an SUV Land Rover, or BMW,
or Porsche.
Alfa Romeo is coming
out with an SUV.
And then you have to have
blond dogs and blond kids.
Those blondes are
afraid of leftovers.
So they go and they
buy their meal,
and then they throw
the leftovers away.
You don't have to
throw leftovers away.
You could turn your leftovers
from leftover spaghetti
and you can keep it in the
fridge for up to a week
if it doesn't have
meat juices in it,
and you can spread it
out in a buttered pan
and beat up some eggs and throw
it in and make a frittata out
of leftover spaghetti.
You can make it
into something else.
That's what people don't know.
They say, oh, we
don't like leftovers,
but good cooks know that you
can take leftovers and turn it
into something else.
What is salad nicoise?
Leftover green beans,
leftover potatoes.
Throw a can of tuna fish on.
Am I right?
The sources of food waste are
the farm, the distribution
center, the grocery
store, and the home.
And so if we can try and
pick up at those places
and teach people how to
reuse their leftovers
and not buy too much
that they don't need
and don't worry about
expiration dates,
then we can help to
avoid food waste.
What can we do
about people here?
So I am 70-fucking-6
years old, and I'm
at the age where if
I go to a restaurant,
I don't eat all the food.
So what's happening for my
generation is a lot of people
will eat half their
portion of chicken or fish
or whatever it is and
then ask for a little box
to take the rest
home in, then they
eat it cold for
lunch the next day.
That's what older women do.
But how can you
teach Googlers not
to take so much on their
plate and then they think,
oh, well it's being composted.
Still, you don't need
to take so much food
if you're not going to eat it.
How do you teach
people not to do it?
I don't know.
You tell them about
the 76-year-old lady
that has a little box to
take home and eat it cold
the next day.
OK, next-- what we all know
is that if I take a plate of--
today, I had delicious lentils
and noodles here for lunch.
If I take too much
food on my plate,
I can put it in a little
box and take it home.
But the food that was all
out on the buffet that
is not reusable for
another day, all
can be packaged and donated.
And that's why we have
so much tins of food
from businesses like yours
that we pick up and take
to the shelters.
This is a list of
the five places
that your food is donated
to five days a week.
So you don't have
to hang out there.
Come on, stand up.
Look, we're the
Christmas girls--
green and red.
So the last place,
the Derek Silva,
it's 68 units of
affordable housing.
It is for people
living with HIV/AIDS.
And so the food that Google is
donating through Food Runners,
every day has been taken
to those five places--
an agency serving
hot meals to anybody
that comes to the door,
a mental health treatment
program for ex-cons, a church
serving meals to the homeless,
Canon Kip is elderly,
and Derek Silva is HIV.
So those people are totally
spoiled by your food.
And could we take
more from Google?
The answer is yes.
We can take the yogurt
that's over there.
We can take the fruit
that's in the cafes.
We can take everything
that has not
been served on a
plate to somebody
sitting there, spitting
on it, and putting
their fingers in it, OK?
For instance, I'll take
those pumpkins when I leave.
[LAUGHTER]
I'll put those in my purse.
All buffet food is donatable.
We pick up at the Hilton today.
We're picking up at
the Ritz-Carlton today.
From the Ritz-Carlton, it's
taken about nine months, where,
first, we got their
leftover banquet food,
and now we're getting
the leftover food
from the takeout places.
But it's just amazing
the misinformation
that people have.
I heard once about somebody--
it was actually a
Bon Appétit company.
Down in the peninsula, Bon
Appétit is the food provider.
They put out yogurt in an ice
bath, and when the ice melts,
they throw the yogurt out.
I mean, that's ridiculous.
Yogurt is bacteria.
Yogurt keeps forever.
[LAUGHTER]
So no food needs
to be thrown away.
You can donate it.
Just put it in a package
and call Food Runners.
So can I have the next--
the next one's probably a photo.
So what is food waste?
Food waste has
many sources, but I
think it's kind of uneducated
people that don't know
or it's people that don't care--
one more-- or they're in the
habit of throwing food away.
It takes a long time to get
people to change their habits.
And so the habits are take only
what you think you can eat,
save the rest to
donate, and see that
a responsible organization,
like Food Runners,
picks it up and takes it
where it can best be used.
The next thing that I think what
you can help Food Runners with
is, first of all, maybe we could
pass these out to everybody
and pass these out to everybody.
So the deal is that because
I'm an old secretary,
I do things with
cards and brochures,
but hold on to these.
And so we're still kind
of in the process--
at Food Runners, we're
kind of in the "pro-cess"--
that's Canadian for process.
We're kind of in the process
of trying to get more
into the new technology.
For instance, we are
working on an app,
but currently, people can donate
through the website or the app.
We still have a phone
with an answering service.
So people can call
and leave a message
on an answering service--
I mean a voicemail.
But I think how you
can help, as Googlers,
as San Franciscans, and
as concerned people,
is first of all,
tell your friends.
Tell your friends.
The best volunteers for us are
people who are in between jobs.
People who are in between jobs.
That's fine.
People who are in
between jobs or recently
retired make really
good volunteers
because they're used to
getting up and going somewhere.
So if you know anybody
that's recently
retired or between jobs, and
they have their own vehicle,
this is a really good
place to volunteer,
is with Food Runners.
We also could use help
through social media
by taking pictures of the food
you're donating and saying,
this is going to neighborhood
shelters through Food Runners.
So we could use the
help with social media.
We can use help with telling
everybody you know with food.
And what else can
we use help with?
If you know anybody with a car--
So I want to tell
you a little bit more
about some of the people
that are volunteers for us.
There's a man who came here--
actually, I shouldn't say this,
but he also came
here in the '50s
and earned his living
as a drug dealer.
And then he went into the
waterproofing and painting
business.
And this guy has been picking
up, at the Ferry Plaza Farmers
Market, all the leftover
food from the farmers
every Saturday whenever
he's in San Francisco.
He goes and gets the truck.
We use a truck for
large donations.
He goes and gets the
truck, and he's a Brit.
So you can see him
at 1:30, 12:30,
1:00 o'clock at the
Ferry building going,
Food Runners, Food Runners,
bring out your food.
So it takes him
four hours every day
to deliver all the food that
the farmers bring him because he
has a relationship with them.
And then the farmers
at the Ferry building
bring him up even extra
food on Saturdays.
There is another
guy, kind of who
I would call a trust fund baby.
He's a well-to-do
man who lives out
on Washington Street
in Pacific Heights
and he has a
17-year-old daughter.
And he and his daughter go
on food runs every Saturday.
He does Saturday at Kara's
Cupcakes on Steiner Street--
no, Scott Street.
And he takes bread
and pastries out
to the veteran's
home up on Presidio.
That's on Saturday.
On Sunday, he goes to the
farmers market at Fort Mason
and picks up all
their leftover foods
and takes it to a place
called Walden House--
that I call Walden house--
on Hays and Fillmore.
And then there's a guy
called Sam Haskins.
Sam Haskins will go
today at about 3:30
to a restaurant
called [INAUDIBLE],,
who makes foil trays
of food for him.
He's a lawyer who writes books.
We also have women
doing deliveries, too.
The volunteers for Food
Runners, some of them
have been volunteers
for 30 years.
Some people like to
know that they're
going to go every
Friday at 4:00 o'clock
in the afternoon to
pick up the leftover
food at the Williams-Sonoma
corporate office.
And some people like to know
that they're going to go.
Oh, there's a brand new place.
I don't know if
you've been to it.
It's called Meraki.
It's a society deli on Post
between Larkin And Hyde
that just opened two weeks ago.
A guy called Stanlee
Gatti is the owner,
and he brought in a bunch
of New York hotshots
and they put all this kombucha,
and sauerkraut, and chia seeds,
and all these trendy
food in there.
Then you go, what are
they doing on Post
between Larkin and Hyde?
It's kind of like a
renters neighborhood,
but they've got all the society
people coming in their limos,
and they send their
chauffeurs to pick up food.
But that new deli on Post
Street is giving off all
their leftover food--
I went and picked up myself--
every night at 9:00 o'clock
the first week they were open.
And now, they save
the food in the cooler
and we pick it up the next day.
Have you been there?
AUDIENCE: No, I was just
thinking it might the old Fleur
de Lis spot.
MARY RISLEY: That's on Sutter.
This is Post.
It's a kind of crappy building.
So I got to tell more jokes
or he got a phone call.
[LAUGHTER]
So anyway, we pick up at
bakeries, grocery stores,
delis like this
place, Mollie Stone's.
So listen to this.
So I am in Mollie Stone's
all the time on California
and Franklin, and
it's taken me 10 years
to get the Mollie Stone's to
donate their leftover food.
And what changed their mind was
I named my dog Mollie Stone.
I got a new dog last year
and called it Mollie Stone.
[LAUGHTER]
But you know, it's hard
to convince people,
as I said, to
change their habits,
but we have 200 volunteers.
We're picking up
500 times a week
with a van, a truck,
and our volunteers
with regular runs, and then
other people that are on-call.
Some people just like to be
on-call, get in their car
and go.
And we also pick up--
I talked about the
Ritz-Carlton and the Hilton.
We also pick up from caterers.
There's a big caterer
called Dan McCall,
who has a commissary
kitchen on 17th Street.
He will take back his leftover
food to the commissary kitchen,
and we'll come the next
day and pick it up.
There's another caterer called
Paula LeDuc out of Emeryville.
So she doesn't take
it back to Emeryville.
She calls us and we pick
it up at 1:30 at night.
So somebody suggested
recently that maybe we
should have Uber drivers.
We should have Uber--
because of their
bad reputation--
sponsor cars going around
and picking up food for us.
And you go, oh, I
don't know because they
might Get creamed chicken all
over the back of their car.
So anyway, the regular
people, we have 500 people--
no, 150 people, a
truck driver, a van,
and a couple of cargo
bikes going around
and picking up food either as
regular runners or volunteers.
And I still need that last
thing about the call to action.
The call to action.
What can you do to help?
You can help us
with social media.
You can help us with spreading
the word to food businesses.
You can help us with
letting anybody who
might want to be a volunteer--
no.
And then the fourth
way, I can't remember.
So we'll have to
get back to that.
We'll get back to spread
the word, tell your friends,
and help us get more food to
those in need in San Francisco.
Before I open it
up for questions,
I want to tell you
a little bit more
about this place that I like to
take food to while-- oh, yes.
Listen to this.
So the other day, somebody
donated three garbage bags
full of these paper
containers that you
might take soup home in.
So I took them to Walden House.
But I want to tell you
about Walden House.
Walden House is now
called HealthRIGHT 360,
and they recruit men
and women coming out
of jail who've had repeated--
who keep going back to having
drugs and getting into trouble.
And they house them
for six months.
And so it's a rehab center.
They have eight locations
in San Francisco.
And what has happened is
that because of the food
that we bring them from people
like you, that has saved them
$2 million a year that
they would otherwise
have to spend on buying
and making food for them.
So thank you, Google,
for all your food.
Thank you for YouTube
where I got my fame.
And what kind of
questions do you
have for me about food rescue,
food waste, and Food Runners?
SPEAKER 1: I see I've
got two questions
from Kevin [INAUDIBLE].
So he has two questions for you.
So what policies
should we be trying
to pass to lower
barriers to sharing food?
MARY RISLEY: What policies--
SPEAKER 1: Yes.
MARY RISLEY: --should we pass?
SPEAKER 1: Yes, to lower
barriers to sharing food.
MARY RISLEY: There
are no policies.
Just pick up the fucking food.
SPEAKER 1: OK, the second
one, should be more actively
push people to be vegetarians
given that [INAUDIBLE]..
MARY RISLEY: So should we
push people to be vegetarians?
I don't think that has anything
to do with rescuing food.
Listen to this.
In San Francisco,
it's well-known
that the homeless people
are the pickiest eaters.
So if you were to go serve
food at Glide or St. Anthony
or Martin de Porres
you do have people
going through the line saying,
does that have sugar in it?
Does that have gluten in it?
Even the homeless and the
hungry are picky eaters here.
But I think vegetarianism
is a personal choice.
Yes sweetheart?
AUDIENCE: Hello, hello,
hello, testing, testing.
I was just curious, what
inspired the inspiration
for the initial--
here you were.
You were running
a cooking school.
And then you decided to
start this Food Runner
some time later.
You said 1987.
What was happening
at that moment?
What did you see?
MARY RISLEY: Quite frankly I
used to stop in my red Alfa
Romeo at the corner of--
every day I crossed the corner
of Chestnut and Columbus.
And you'd see people going
through the garbage looking
for food.
And so what I did, at one
time at my cooking school
we did a two-day
wedding-cake workshop.
And so at the end of the
two days, we cut into them,
we tasted it, but I had
seven wedding cakes.
Do I drive them to Glide?
Do I give them to the staff?
Or do I throw them
in the garbage?
And so I thought, there
must be other people
in the food business that
have that same question.
And the truth is I
still have that car too.
And I still have buttercream
all over the steering wheel
because I drove it to Glide.
I drove those wedding
cakes to Glide in 1986.
I approached the
mayor's office--
Dianne Feinstein
was the mayor then--
and said I have food
connections, can we help?
And she introduced me
to a woman in Berkeley
who was kind of a whole
Mother Earth type of woman.
And she taught me
how to do this.
And so we started with a small
group of people, Food Runners,
saying we're going to
provide this free service
to any business
in San Francisco.
And so what do you do if you
have a party in your home
and then not everybody comes?
So what you can do as
a home cook is package
the food and you can look on
foodrunners.org, the website,
and it'll tell you where
your neighborhood place
that you can take food to.
If you live in North
Beach, you can take it
to North Beach Citizens.
If you live out by-- there's
a place called Edgewood out
by the zoo, things like that.
So we can't pick up in homes,
but home food can be taken.
OK, does that answer
your question?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
And one more quick
question-- have
you seen the
documentary "Wasted",
and what do you think of
Anthony fucking Bourdain?
[LAUGHTER]
MARY RISLEY: I haven't
seen the documentary.
They asked me if I would in it.
And he's definitely a newcomer
to the whole thing, you know?
Have you seen the documentary?
AUDIENCE: We just saw it.
MARY RISLEY: Was it any good?
AUDIENCE: It was
actually pretty good.
MARY RISLEY: Yeah.
So Tony Bourdain, as you
know, has made his reputation
as a bad boy, throwing
cigarette butts in melted butter
and restaurants where he worked
in Grand Central Station.
But he has great writers
and great producers.
And so if they're helping the
food movement, God bless them.
AUDIENCE: Hello, hello.
MARY RISLEY: Hi.
Hello, hello.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
I was introduced to your
company about 10 years
while working in grocery,
working on Whole Foods.
And so it was a very
interesting moment
of just like the
idea of food waste
and how it's being acknowledged.
And it seems perhaps
like you guys
could have been kind of
like setting an industry
standard for such.
And I'm curious if--
MARY RISLEY: I think we were--
AUDIENCE: --other cities--
MARY RISLEY: --one of the
first in the country, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so have
other cities come to you?
MARY RISLEY: I
think totally, yeah.
So what happens is there is
now a kind of a food waste--
I mean a food recovery group in
Sonoma County that I trained.
There's one in Marin
County that I helped train.
There's one on the peninsula.
I helped train.
There's one in
Wilkes-Barre, Pennsylvania
that I helped work with.
There's one in
Northwest Connecticut.
And there's a great
one in Toronto
that I didn't have
anything to do with.
But food waste is
becoming a huge topic.
And I even saw it on the
side of a moving van.
I can't remember the name
of the moving company,
but it had a big sign on it
saying moveforhunger.org.
And it appears that
the moving company
that's getting
all your furniture
and taking it
somewhere will also
take all your food from your
cupboards and donate it.
So food waste is becoming
a really good topic.
And it's great that everybody
is becoming involved in it.
Any other questions?
So the other thing that
I am going to finish with
is, I know that most of you are
trained professionals in food.
And I want to tell
you a story about--
so we had a truck donated
to us 20 years ago from UPS,
and it was a refrigerated truck.
And so I went to a party
at the middle of the night,
put all the donated food in it.
We used a parking space
at Royal Hawaiian Seafood
and plugged it in.
I plugged in.
But the next day I went
back to get the truck
to deliver the food
to the shelters
and it was clear that the
refrigeration didn't work.
And so I had big bags of carrots
and celery, bread, and bags
of cooked chicken.
And so what I did was I drove
the truck to 5th and Bryant,
to the shelter at
5th and Bryant,
and taking the bags
of bread inside,
taking the carrots inside.
And I tried to put the
chicken into the dumpster.
And the homeless guys that were
waiting to get in the shelter
started climbing
in the dumpster.
And I'm like, oh, no,
no, you can't eat that.
It'll make you sick.
And they go, "Lady,
we're hungry."
You know, there's no
need to fear liability.
And I don't care what the
health department says
in San Francisco or
Wilkes-Barre, Pennsylvania
or Truckee, California.
If you let the
health department--
I mean of course you have
to obey their rules when
you're in the food business.
But they will try
and tell you, oh, it
has to be chilled at this
temperature and raised to the--
and take the
fucking temperature.
No, it's food and
they're hungry people.
They're not going to follow
you out the door to find out
where the salad is going.
I'm an old hippie from the '60s.
We can't be run by
rules and regulations
when there are hungry people.
And we have to, as
civilized human beings,
we have to take care of
our fellow human beings.
As far as I know,
we're the only animal
in the world that heats food
and makes it taste good.
We aren't like deer or raccoons
going around the Presidio
picking up food.
And we have to take care
of our fellow human beings.
And with one out of
every four people
going to bed hungry
in San Francisco,
we need to do everything
we can to help them.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]